buongiorno e grazie di essere qui
parleremo oggi di un
idea
quando ho iniziato a fare lavoro nel
occupandomi di sicurezza urbana
convivenza immigrazione
spesso
mi veniva detto che c'era in città un
quartiere dove era praticamente
impossibile lavorare combinare qualcosa
di buono io ho pensato con i nostri
collaboratori che se volevamo essere
credibili su un tema della convivenza
bisognava andare dove il problema era
più appunto dove effettivamente
succedevano spesso anche elementi
negativi e ridare fiducia ai cittadini
se fossimo riusciti a produrre qualcosa
di buono
sarebbe stato utile non solo per i
residenti di quella di quelle realtà ma
sarebbe stata utile per tutta la città
abbiamo utilizzato questo paragone del
fatto di dire che quando
una parte il nostro corpo sta male
effettivamente tutto il corpo che ne
risente basti pensare anche un semplice
raffreddore e allora in quel caso che
cosa si fa
ci si cura ci si rafforza e si combatte
e quello che è avvenuto appunto
nella zona stazione abbiamo detto che
quello è il luogo più difficile
luogo anche malato qualche volta della
nostra città allora bisogna concentrare
in quel luogo le energie migliori per
divenire credibili agli occhi dei
cittadini e dare una risposta
il contesto rimane tuttora dopo tre anni
di lavoro difficile non abbiamo risolto
tutto ci sono comunque ancora
contraddizioni molta strada è stato
fatto però abbiamo trasmesso l'idea che
era possibile produrre il cambiamento
a questo punto di vista quindi il nostro
è stato un lavoro molto di come dire
anche di cambiamento del modo di
lavorare della stessa pubblica
amministrazione e quindi non più solo un
settore ma il commercio urbanistica il
sociale insieme che cercano di dare una
risposta collegiale di mostrare un volto
unito e la pubblica amministrazione e
poi facciamo leanza facciamo alleanza
con i commercianti con tantissime
associazioni e soprattutto il prezioso
sostegno delle forze dell'ordine che
hanno contribuito con controlli puntuali
a ristabilire
alcune regole fondamentali quindi il
giusto equilibrio nel saper produrre gli
interventi e nel sapere effettivamente
mostrare un volto unitario della
pubblica amministrazione capace di
essere nuovamente
credibili e quindi allora semplicemente
abbiamo iniziato
mandando anche fare incontri diretti con
i cittadini camminando lungo le strade
vedendo le cose che non funzionavano
anche dal punto di vista della
manutenzione delle strisce che non erano
disegnate bene e dei marciapiedi della
del traffico e su questo produrre
effettivamente diciamo un un progetto
iniziale che poteva essere appunto di
prima manutenzione ma soprattutto come
dire far sì che tutto questo fossero
coinvolti fin dall'inizio
i cittadini e quindi allora cerchiamo di
far diventare quel quartiere una
priorità dichiariamo il nostro amore per
reggio ma soprattutto per quel partiro
meglio anche per quel quartiere
ovviamente più facile forse frequentare
i salotti buoni della città è più
difficile andare in quelle situazioni
di questo abbiamo cercato di parlare e
mettere all'ordine del nostro lavoro il
tema nuovo della convivenza per chiarire
effetto effettivamente che la città era
cambiata che la presenza dei migranti
non poteva essere temporanea ma era
strutturale ormai c'è un mondo del
lavoro che nelle città e che non
potevano esservi quartieri chiusi a sé
stante ma tutto doveva effettivamente
convivere la convivenza non è facile
conflitto c'è tuttora esiste e va
affrontato per quel che
poiché per quello che ci propone sono
neanche le risposte che devono essere
come dire misurate allora sicuramente le
regole la convivenza ma soprattutto la
responsabilità di ognuno di noi nel dare
delle
nell'assumersi responsabilità per i
ruoli che che svolgiamo e quindi di
sapere anche comunicare in modo molto
chiaro qual era il nostro obiettivo del
fatto che tutti potevano assumere una
dimensione e appunto far sì che questo
luogo potesse divenire un luogo dove
incontrarsi vivere come avviene anche in
piazza trampolino in sala del tricolore
e pertanto allora cerchiamo di ridare
fiducia ai cittadini
incominciamo a fare
di workshop sia nei nostri uffici ad
ascoltare ea prendere impegni con
programmi e andiamo nel quartiere
ascoltiamo e soprattutto definiamo un
programma e si arriva effettivamente a
definirlo questo questo programma e
l'abbiamo chiamato patto dove tutti i
cittadini sono stati inizialmente 150
poi l'anno dopo altri un altro anno
un'altra cinquantina hanno sottoscritto
con il sindaco
impegni precisi che dovevano essere
rispettati gli impegni di manutenzione
del territorio di convivenza nei
condomini e appunto di gestione abbiamo
chiesto ai cittadini a fronte del nostro
impegno di aiutarci a gestire meglio il
il territorio e quindi un grande
progetto anche di partecipazione e noi
abbiamo detto che tutte le cose che
avremmo fatto in quel quartiere avremo
condivise per tempo con i cittadini
quindi diventare questo punto di vista
credibili con delle azioni e questo
forse è
diciamo l'episodio che ha significato
maggiormente il cambiamento l'inizio del
cambiamento ci avevamo un uno spazio
molto degradato un parcheggio coperto
che era fonte di
violenza di spaccio di prostituzione
e allora concordiamo con i cittadini di
abbattere quel parcheggio di fare una
piazza un luogo di incontro
dove le famiglie potessero incontrarsi i
bambini andare a giocare è un bar quindi
analcolico gestito da una cooperativa
sociale e di far sì che quel luogo
diventi il motore di una nuova
convivente 15 un progetto di
manutenzione del territorio ma
soprattutto un un'idea di condividere
meglio di sullo spazio pubblico di
riappropriarsi degli spazi questo
abbiamo chiesto ai cittadini
a questo punto di vista il progetto poi
continuato è tuttora continua con il
recupero del del parco delle paura di un
nuovo campo di calcio l'illuminazione la
pulizia delle strade che è giornaliera e
accanto questo bar oltre alle famiglie
poi ruotano anche i nostri operatori di
strada
avevamo
abbiamo tuttora un forte consumo di
alcolici in luogo pubblico i cosiddetti
bivacchi e allora abbiamo pensato
rapporto problema anche di qualche volta
di spaccio gli spazi sufficienti ma c'è
soprattutto un problema di condivisione
di spazi abbiamo messo gli operatori di
strada hanno parlato quotidianamente
tuttora lo fanno aiutano queste persone
ad andare al sert servizi sociali alcuni
sono tornati grazie al nostro lavoro nei
loro paesi d'origine altri addirittura
uno in particolare ha scoperto che
poiché aveva lavorato a reggio emilia
per lungo tempo non sapeva che aveva
diritto alla pensione altri sono stati
avviati a piccoli lavori utili di questo
il quartiere ed 8 informato e c'è una
relazione strettissima tra i residenti e
gli operatori di strada che segnalano le
cose che non vanno
noi abbiamo avuto un crollo delle
segnalazioni di conflittualità con i
viva molte cose le abbiamo risolti sono
state sanate un rim presenta tuttora di
un forte consumo di alcolici in quelle
zone
credo che questo sia un esempio di come
effettivamente non abbiamo sistemato
l'alcolismo abbiamo però dato una
risposta alla convivenza lavoro in
progress perché ogni giorno
effettivamente nasce una problematicità
e poi abbiamo lavorato con le famiglie
la prima cosa che abbiamo fatto abbiamo
suonato i campanelli nei condomini
perchè c'erano situazioni di difficoltà
cosa più tasse perché può accadere e il
fatto che in un appartamento al venerdì
sera ci sia una festa con 60 persone che
bevono e questo crea oggettivamente
all'anziano che abita di problemi avevo
parlato con queste persone tutto questo
oggi non c'è più
ed è stato un importante lavoro di
mediazione condominiale il punto critico
del quartiere e ancora oggi il forte
indebitamento che ogni condominio a
gente che aveva smesso di pagare la luce
o gas le spese condominiali portando non
solo la continuità mettendo in crisi la
convivente bene da quest'anno sono stati
fatti piani di rientro del debito
i cittadini hanno ripreso a pagare gli
onesti hanno ripreso il controllo di
molti condomini e hanno emarginato i
furbi e anche chi speculava sulle loro
difficoltà perché c'è anche chi specula
immobiliaristi e non solo tutto questo è
stato possibile grazie al fatto della
prestazione che ha come dire aviatori
avviato un meccanismo il lavoro di
condominio oggi noi non abbiamo il
titolo entrare in condominio perché
proprietà privata abbiamo semplicemente
chiamato tutti i soggetti
dagli amministratori ai proprietari
abbiamo coinvolto la polizia municipale
gli operatori culturali insieme a me lo
ha visto punto per punto dando una
risposta e soprattutto oi progetti
educativi di portare i bambini in
particolare i ragazzi cinesi che hanno
riscoperto i loro giochi tradizionali
ecco tutto questo in relazione con i
progetti che avvengono in città quindi
cinque azioni che vengono proposte in
questo progetto non sono isolate ma su
un in dialogo tra di loro tant'è che poi
la pubblica amministrazione tiene due
volte all'anno una propria conferenza
dei servizi dove tutti gli operatori del
comune dicono quello che stanno facendo
in quell'area e insieme progettiamo
delle delle azioni e così credo anche
sul tema della partecipazione abbiamo
scritto cose importante sappiamo che qui
vi sono circa il 70 per cento di
cittadini di origine straniera e quindi
è stato difficile l'approccio
linguistico ma soprattutto spiegarsi su
cosa vogliamo fare e quindi è divenuto
un grande progetto di partecipazione di
condivisione degli spazi pubblici ma
anche di convivenza di culture diverse
tante che poi abbiamo deciso anche con i
cittadini di produrre un
un evento che si chiama 167 contato un
festival dove i residenti
producono attraverso l'arte la cultura
un modo diverso anche di
condividere e di vivere lo stesso lo
stesso quartiere
e questo punto sono alcune e poiché
abbiamo detto che l'amore è contagiosa
abbiamo poi con contattato la regione
emilia romagna che ha sposato questo
progetto tant'è che questo campetto di
calcio è stato possibile grazie al
contributo della regione emilia romagna
abbiamo contattato il regno del marocco
che
impressionato dalla presenza marocchina
nel quartiere ma soprattutto dalla forse
novità di poter contribuire non singolo
simulazione ma di essere inseriti in un
contesto
articolato dove effettivamente la
cultura potesse avere un ruolo hanno
deciso di investire su questa su
quest'area è il rapporto col governo del
marocco è stato fondamentale perché
abbiamo cominciato a cambiare l'idea si
e reggiani hanno degli stranieri o dei
paesi di origine quindi non solo
fonte di problemi ma anche aiuto a
gestire le situazioni e soprattutto un
elemento paritario
affrontare questioni che non sono solo
reggiane ma sono globali che tutti i
paesi hanno la cosa divertente è che nel
rapporto coi cittadini poi la stessa
regione emilia romagna e anche lo stesso
ministero degli interni che allora era
molto come gliele sicurtà hryo hanno
riconosciuto in questa nostra filosofia
una chiave di lettura che non significa
aver risolto tutti i problemi ma la
convivenza la sicurezza urbana la
gestione degli spazi ha bisogno di un
progetto unitario dove tutti i soggetti
pubblici e privati debole di loro di
dialogare
poi sicuramente convivenza bisogno anche
del rispetto delle regole ma queste
fondamentali e vorrei quindi ritornare
questo proverbio africano che abbiamo
adottato perché per me è un proverbio
reggiano profondamente reggiano cioè se
vuoi andare veloce vai da solo se vuoi
andare lontano va insieme agli altri e
allora io ricordo che noi abbiamo detto
tempo fa molto tempo fa dobbiamo
ricordarcelo sempre farlo vivere
quotidianamente dello star che cosa
significa stare insieme per insieme non
è un elemento buonista è una strategia
di lungo periodo è una strategia
politica di far contare le persone di sé
l'essenza politica che cos'è oggi la
politica se non quella di organizzare le
persone condividere insieme un obiettivo
e insieme realizzarlo questo è un
insegnamento
lo dico tranquillamente anche per chi
oggi cerca delle soluzioni ad uscire da
questa situazione di difficoltà di non
credibilità dei partiti
quello è un esempio e cioè dello stare
insieme
e allora se
tanto tempo fa qui è nato è nata una
persona che ha detto se
divisi siamo nulla uniti siamo tutto e
da lì è iniziato un percorso rilevante
di cambiamento eravamo poverissimi
a fine ottocento e grazie a quella
strategia la nostra città è diventata
forte dal punto di vista politico
economico le persone da poverissime sono
diventate benestanti in termini positivi
e hanno dato un valore aggiunto
quello è stato possibile grazie a questa
strategia e noi dobbiamo recuperarla al
più presto questo è un esempio vero di
come occorre poter gestire i quartieri e
coinvolgere le persone che si tratti di
italiani o stranieri non importa questo
è
amoreggio e io penso che insieme in
rimonta